okay in this video we're going to be
discussing how to find linear speed and
angular speed so a lot of times students
have questions about this concept how do
I find linear speed and angular speed it
seems like a real difficult concept but
really all it is is doing a unit
conversion or unit analysis type problem
so I'll show you an example so say for
example we want to find out what the
angular speed is for
a wheel that's turning at 4 revolutions
per minute
okay so just a wheel that's rotating at
4 revolutions per minute so what you do
is you start off with 4 revolutions per
one minute okay and what you want to do
is you want to convert into the angular
speed so that's the angle per unit time
so what we're going to do is we're going
to multiply by 2 pi radians per 1
revolution so if you remember unit
circle 2 pi radians is what one
revolution is equivalent to and so your
revolutions cancel and now you have
radians per minute if you multiply the
numerators and denominators you get 8 pi
radians per minute so that's your angle
per unit time your angular speed
now if you want to find your linear
speed say this wheel that we're
discussing let's just say it has a three
foot diameter so say this is three feet
and if we remember that circumference
equals pi times diameter so
circumference the distance all the way
around so the circumference is going to
be 3 pi feet for every one revolution so
you go once around that distance is 3 pi
feet for every one turn where every one
rotation so if we want to convert from 4
revolutions per minute
to the linear speed linear[speed] is like the
length per unit time we've got four revs
per one minute and we're going to
multiply by for every one revolution
you're going to be traveling 3pi feet so
three PI feet so you can see that the
revolutions cancel and you end up with
feet per minute so let's just multiply
across that's 12 pi feet per one minute
okay so that's angular speed and linear
speed so the next problem I want to show
you this one's a little bit more
complicated some students have trouble
with this but again just think about
converting from the unit's that you
don't want into the unit's that you do
want so let's take a look at that
problem so what we're going to do in
this one we'll analyze a vehicle that's
traveling at 60 miles per hour okay some
type of a vehicle is traveling at 60
miles per hour and let's just say that
the tires on this vehicle let's just say
that they're 1.5 feet okay that's the
diameter which means that the
circumference is 1.5 pi feet per one Rev
and let's say we want to convert to
revolutions per minute so we're starting
with 60 miles per hour the vehicles
traveling we're going to convert miles
into feet
so one mile for every 5,280 feet so see
how the miles cancel numerator and
denominator so you end up with feet per
hour now the feet we know there's 1.5 PI
feet per revolution so let's convert 1.5
PI feet per 1 Rev so the feet cancels
the numerator denominator they cancel
now we have revolutions per hour we want
to convert that into
revolutions per minute okay so right now
we've got hours so let's see here we've
got for every one hour there are 60
minutes so you can see the hours are
cancelling with the hours denominator
and numerator and we're going to end up
with the units we do want which are
revolutions per minute
your revolutions per minute so all you
have to do is multiply across all the
numerators all the denominators and
divide so we'll just do that real quick
on the calculator so you have that if
you want to compare 60 times 5,280 okay
divided by in parentheses 1.5 pi times
60 so we get one thousand one hundred
and twenty point five so one thousand
one hundred and twenty point five
revolutions per minute so these are a
couple examples for finding linear speed
angular speed just think of it as a unit
conversion problem and that'll make it
simple to solve so check out some of my
other videos if you have other questions
regarding problems you're having with
your math and if you need to review this video again to understand
these problems better, see you in the next video